let's get started with this uh this
first story and this one is
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
is pleased at the prospect of trump
being impeached new report says when i
think of mitch mcconnell being pleased
i want to think of like mr burns going
excellent but mcconnell's kind of like a
turtle
excellent you know it reminds me of like
disney
they say uh from business insider senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell believes
president donald trump has committed
multiple impeachable offenses and is
pleased at the idea of trump being
impeached and removed from office
the new york times reported on tuesday
the democratic-controlled house is
expected to vote on impeaching trump on
a charge of inciting an insurrection on
the u.s capitol on wednesday
this would make trump the first
president in american history to be
impeached twice
mcconnell thinks that trump being
impeached and then potentially convicted
and ousted from office by the u.s senate
will make it easier to
purge him from the party the time said
citing people familiar with his thinking
oh please i always love when they put
those lines in there
familiar with his thinking what does
that mean it's basically new york times
does that all the time yeah it's an
excuse to not have to be a journalist
so you can just basically say oh well
someone familiar with his thinking
and then no one can really hold you to
account because what does that even mean
it means some random person was like
oh i bet i bet he wants to uh you know
purge trump
well you've read you know if you've
watched enough fox news you know mitch
mcconnell thinks
yeah we'll roll with it yeah everyone's
familiar with all of these criminals
thinking
at this point but they're they're
familiar with trump's thinking yeah
we're all very familiar with trump um
but now he can't he can't uh express
what he's thinking on twitter anymore
i think wouldn't it be funny if like
donald trump because the last thing he
really has is that the old school thing
where the president can interrupt
broadcast television but like if trump
just did it like every 15 minutes to
like
tell you what he was going to tweet like
he just comes in and he's like we have
the biggest crowd sizes
all right i'll be back i mean what if we
just happy
no but what if he just did it and it was
just him hanging out
and he just talked for hours and all tv
was just taken over
he's so funny he also has the
presidential texting system yeah that's
right we can go when it'll be like trump
saying you know we had a huge rally it
was the biggest everyone agrees
i did nothing wrong could you imagine
getting his tweets forcefully because
twitter bans him so he's like
that's kind of been the joke trump trump
supporters are saying he's going to
start spamming
through the presidential alert system
i'd be here for it that's pretty
entertaining
i'd be i i think it'd be a good time you
know you know life is fairly boring and
routine
you know and this path these past
several years have been so psychotic
and just everything constantly getting
crazier and crazier i think everybody's
like a little vacation
maybe maybe that's that's the good with
with boring old biden
who fumbles and mumbles and doesn't give
pressers at the very least
people the media i should say won't have
anything to talk about
yeah i guess the ramifications are the
political destruction that will come
following this so oh yeah no that's bad
it's pretty bad if you know you're like
a citizen in syria or something like
that but there i think a lot of people
voted for
them for that reason yeah but i think
taiwan are freaking out
yeah and they maybe they should be uh
but i think a lot of people
it's not just trump fatigue it's like
the the media fatigue too like they're
just so
over this whole thing and just want like
people
crave normal no the media is panicking
like well yeah they're actually there
there's a journalist i'm not gonna say
her name but she tweeted
i don't know what i'm going to do like
my whole career was built upon
donald trump and now trump's gone is
nothing to write about well
did you see that that reply guy to trump
who was just like
it's more unsettling not knowing what
trump is thinking it's like oh
he's going to cry now is it unsettling
or do you just realize you have no
meaning in your life
so that might be what's unsettling but i
think the problem
that all of the establishment types are
going to run into because this is a big
moment for them like they've they got
the guy out who they wanted to get out
then they have this great excuse with
the capital riot where they can be like
aha see we were right about everything
and right-wing violence and all of this
stuff and then they go well maybe we'll
impeach him now and that'll purge him
from
the problem is that the 74 million
people who voted for donald trump
the vast vast vast majority still really
really like donald trump
and the the core of it is that they like
his policies better than the neocon
policies
that what he stood for and i like some
of it
not all of it don't like the job he did
as a president but
if somebody gets up there and gives a
jeb bush policy
this is what we need to do we need to
invade every country in the middle east
have wide open borders
bail out banks what you know what i mean
like the bush
policies and then trump says how about
we actually restrict immigration don't
fight these stupid wars
re-look at some of these trade deals
make sure it works for america and we're
not outsourcing jobs
that is enormously more popular amongst
the republican base and they can't purge
that well here's the best part
the republicans are i guess doing
everything in their power to figure out
how to never win again
yeah because we have this story from cnn
politics liz cheney
number three house republican to vote to
impeach trump
you know look if if they think this is
gonna win
for them i i don't know what to tell
them because poll after poll even all
the polls that were wrong consistently
show
trump has the overwhelming majority and
i don't mean like 70
i mean 90 to 95 percent of the
republican party supports the president
now here's where i find something really
interesting not that i trust
the new york times too much but jonathan
martin says
a senate republican aide tells me he
thinks there were about 20
give or take republicans who were open
to a conviction
before our story on mcconnell will that
be enough
to actually get to 67 senators i don't
think so
i don't think these people want to end
their careers right now or get primaried
because they
would you you know any any republican
senator who comes out in favor of
impeaching trump
first of all it's not going to do
anything i mean what pence becomes
president for two days
and then joe biden is the 47th president
and then
it's ridiculous maybe they'll impeach
him after he leaves i guess
sure well the daily mail actually just
started a countdown
with the days left to have donald trump
in office and it's uh i think it's at
183 hours right now
and when we look at a lot of these calls
we're seeing john bolton
liz cheney mitch mcconnell not really
the best of the best
taking the front leadership when it
comes to calling for
uh impeachment and again there's they're
specifically trying to get him for quote
incitement of insurrection donald trump
made some very strong statements against
that
today but uh we pretty much see the
establishment
uh trying to purge as mitch mcconnell
was alluding to donald trump from the
republican party i think that was
someone familiar with his thinking
okay no no for real for real business
insider says mcconnell thinks
trump being impeached and then
potentially convicted announced it from
office by the u.s senate quote
will make it easier to purge him from
the party the times
said citing people familiar with his
thinking
they have attributed this quote or this
idea to mcconnell that he never
said these people are wow the media in
this country
is psychotic yeah that is the most
insane trash
i've ever heard but you know what this
is what it's been for the for i mean
it's been this way for a real long time
and it's only getting worse well it's
it's so hard sometimes i felt this way
for the last four years where i just
want like if i even if i have something
i really want to criticize trump on and
i'm like i think he did such a terrible
job with this
then all of his critics are so insane
that you end up spending most of your
time being like okay no i'm sorry
right like no he's not a russian agent
okay like that's not
but then there's legitimate issues like
yemen like like the crazy
weapon weapons deal with saudi arabia
that doesn't
have to be addressed against donald
trump but guess what we're not talking
about those legitimate issues that
actually could change policies we're
talking about if he was a russian agent
based off no evidence at all yes but you
know what but you're right but and the
truth is right
donald trump should be tried for war
crimes for what
he did with the saudi government to the
people of yemen he should he should be
tried and end up sitting in a jail cell
after a trial
uh next to george w bush and barack
obama for the rest of their lives
it's just awful you're talking about the
mass
slaughter starvation of hundreds of
thousands not only that women
the worst humanitarian crisis in the
world right now and it's enough
no uh no no no no no it's worse it's
worse than this
it's worse you're talking about you're
talking about
babies and old people uh start puking
and and diarrheaing themselves to death
because they have cholera because we put
a full the saudis
you know no the saudi u.s coalition yes
in other words the united states of
america
and and their you know propped up regime
in saudi arabia put a full blockade
around what was already the poorest
country in the middle east right
i mean the united nations called it the
number one humanitarian crisis in the
world
i'm sure you could make an argument with
a few other really bad situations but it
is
i mean it is just people should go to
jail
somebody somebody actually commented
right when we started that they believe
trump was the greatest president of our
lives but should be tried for war crimes
both are true it's interesting that's an
interesting that's an interesting thing
but
it could be a statement about the past
presidents we've had and the horrifying
things they've done well he's definitely
he's not as bad as or obama but that's a
big bar
it's a very low bar with a lot of war
criminals with a lot of crimes that
had so many people suffering from it and
another thing to really consider here
there's even
associated press articles and
investigations that looked into how this
saudi u.s coalition was working with al
qaeda
and sunni rebel groups inside of yemen
to go after the the hootsie
iranian-backed rebels in that country
it's pretty much a proxy war between
iran and saudi arabia the united states
is on the side of saudi arabia and
they're doing some
god-awful things behind al-qaeda
and again this is something that even
the associated press admits
and talks about through their own
investigations yes if you could imagine
right and i know like you
like got like kind of made your bones in
like the post-9 11
you know uh world but could you imagine
right even with all of the opposition to
the terror wars
which deserved all of it they were
absolutely horrible but that you would
say like
if i could have grabbed you in 2005 and
told you that in 2020 and 2021
that america would be fighting on the
side
of saudi arabia and al qaeda
in in yemen that we would be that barack
obama
and uh john brennan and the c.i.a and
saudi arabia and turkey and israel would
be
arming al qaeda in iraq and arming isis
that now
we've actually transitioned the war on
terror to the war
for terror is it it would have made
americans heads explode i don't i don't
think so i think that would have been
like sounds about right
i think it would have made their heads
explode as if you said and it was coming
off of a donald trump
presidency yes yeah that might be their
heads would go that might have uh
guess what that's still not as bad as
what bush and obama did because
trump didn't start any new wars so we
still have to admit let's
let's be honest yeah it's it's not as
bad as what biden will do yes
so i i quite possibly i mean we we had
on china uncensored they talked about
some of the people that biden's bringing
on have praised china and defended them
in some of their horrific actions in the
south china so
they argued specifically that a china
rise is good for the global economy and
we need to not stand in the way of china
becoming the
world hegemonic power that's literally
officials that are in the state
department under joe biden that are
coming in right now that are going to be
setting policies
and as we were saying the people of
taiwan and i said this right after the
election are the biggest
losers of this presidential so let me
ask you uh guys then
how much of what was going on with saudi
arabia i mean this this was going on
with brendan this is going on the obama
administration yeah
this started under obama so is this i'm
just saying
the the war in yemen started the
relationship with saudi arabia goes
it goes back to henry kissinger
literally going to saudi arabia and
arguing for the larger petro dollar on
the world
right so henry kissinger again hands in
china hands in
right wing you know dictatorships
left-wing dictatorships and also
establishing saudi arabia as the global
hegemonic power in the middle east so
can i just say because you added that
part and then i have to and you're
absolutely right
and i have to just add the part about
that is that basically what happened was
after world war ii we entered into the
bretton woods uh uh monetary system
right where where
gold was we were on a gold standard at
35
an ounce and basically everyone else was
on a dollar standard
because we had all the gold after world
war ii because everyone else was
destroyed and we had all of it so the
deal was
don't worry you can back your currency
with dollars and that's as good as gold
because you can trade that in for gold
anytime you want
and then we cheated and we had the
federal reserve printing tons of money
and
other people started to sniff this out
because basically we were going to the
moon and fighting a war in vietnam and
doing the great society
and other countries were like wait a
minute i don't think you actually have
the gold for this
and england and france i believe it was
called our bluff
and they said okay we're returning all
of our dollars we want our gold and then
in 71
nixon it basically the first great
default
of american debt said no we're not
giving it to you
and you know they spun it in this like
you know they're trying to undermine the
sovereignty of the dollar thing but
really was like that we were cheating we
didn't have any of it
so then our money was backed by nothing
so following that this was kissinger's
move to go
we'll back it with oil and then
basically you still have some type of
commodity standards and then he went to
saudi arabia right right but it
was essentially backed by our guns and
our military technologies the military
industrial because
because you look at what you know saddam
hussein didn't he want to get off the
dollar for oil
he did gaddafi did a whole bunch of them
they all find themselves on the wrong
side of these wars if they don't want to
play
well so i wonder how much of what
happened during trump's presidency with
saudi arabia in yemen was him inheriting
the problems of the previous
administrations
he didn't start any new wars he did make
mistakes like the missile strike in
syria and hiring bolton
but later on it seems like he was at
least trying you think
he didn't start any new wars he deserves
credit for that for sure
he flirted and got dangerously close in
venezuela and iran and iran
um but didn't and and to his credit
could have and there were a lot of
people around him who wanted those words
i mean bolton was the national security
advisor
when that stuff with the ram was going
it was the only time the mainstream
media praised him oh he actually stopped
criticizing
24 7 nonstop and they were like he's a
great he's a great president he's
showing real leadership
brian williams was literally
family-friendly show
uh releasing liquids from his pants area
when he saw the missiles
flying over into syria that's beautiful
he called it an amazing beautiful
sign of democracy and freedom that's
what they wanted that's what would save
trump if trump was like i'll blow up who
you tell me to that's right
but trump also could trump could have
played it one of two ways and he just
sat in the middle and failed
okay so he could have uh fought another
war
and they would have all loved him and if
he had started another war or two
the the establishment would have rallied
around him cnn would have backed him
because that's how sick these people are
they think about it they accused him of
treason when he met with putin
and said hey let's be friends let's be
let's have the two countries who have 90
of the nuclear weapons in the world
let's have some data here let's be
friends
that to them is treason bombing uh
people in third world countries
that's a great president so he could
have done that and won them or
he could have ended every last one of
these wars and won the american people
and he did nothing he sat in the middle
and he lost exactly
and you know what the the issue for the
media was in my opinion
if it bleeds it leads pictures of bombs
war
is shocking content that they can sell
on a slow news day you turn on these
these channels and they give you nothing
i remember watching segments of like
anderson cooper standing in mud and he's
like it's raining here in this part of
the country and i'm like
their ratings are probably in the gutter
yeah but when they get that war and that
shock footage and they say it's a crisis
and
oh and they they try and sell it trump
wasn't giving him
giving the media their bloodlust there's
a lot of other things there's a
political influence
a lot of these networks well yeah i mean
half of their staff are former cia
former nsa former military industrial
complex
if anyone wants to see bloodlust and
suffering all they have to do is go to
yemen
right right so so they had that option
to highlight that
yeah well they weren't interested in it
because that would have that would have
been an indictment of
all of them and the entire system that
they prop up think about what we saw
under obama
with extrajudicial assassinations how
much of this when they reported on the
war in the conflict
was were they criticizing obama for it
and how much of it was it was general
coverage
you look at the refugee crisis which was
huge news a couple of years ago
mostly with the eastern mediterranean
route these are people coming from syria
iraq afghanistan
etc and that was the fault of george w
bush and barack obama
and the context of it all was general
news coverage
when it comes to donald trump the dude
could you know step on a twig and it
would crack and they'd all start
shrieking at the top of their lungs
and you know i think it is they they
needed to replace that bloodlust with
something
and because trump wasn't giving them
what they wanted both politically
and in the ratings they turned it into
him they found a way to weaponize it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you